[Music]  Thank You Atlanta we are having such a  terrific fun time  [Applause]  everybody and also April Fool's April  [Applause]  Fool's that's right Mr O'Brien  April Fool's you see I'm afraid I won't  be able to make it to the show tonight  as I've been in a terrible boating  accident and I am currently in the  hospital okay jack well that's a great  April Fool's joke  you're welcome it's just that the thing  is you said April Fool's first which  kind of gives it away that's not how  it's done  also you're standing right in front of  me so I can see that you're not in the  hospital  all right I have to come clean mr.  O'Brian this prank has gone on long  enough  you see I wasn't in a boating accident  at all it was two things well I don't  know it was on the news okay all right  and also they're not in the hospital  they're dead  [Applause]  I don't think he quite gets the concept